A ver yo, um
eh, yo me considero 1 político
con principios de de fuertes convicciones.
Usted, el señor casado se le fugó 1 pudemón
y yo me comprometo hoy y aquí
a traerlo de Vuelta a España
y que rinda cuentas ante la justicia de España.
Si hay 1 partido constitucionalista en este país
y en este sistema político,
es el partido socialista.
Garantizaron la ciudadanía catalana
y la el conjunto de la ciudadanía española
de que esa sentencia se VA a cumplir.
No Han tenido amnistía,
no hay 1 referéndum de autodeterminación y lo habrá,
no lo habrá. Primero por convicción personal y política.
Lo que digo
es que hay que acabar con los indultos políticos,
nunca más indultos
por motivos políticos y por motivos económicos,
respetar la independencia del poder judicial.
¿Qué sentido tiene que 1 político indulte a otro? Ninguno,
absolutamente ninguno. Y yo siento vergüenza de eso.
Planteemos la amnistía.
La única respuesta posible
es que eso no es planteable
en 1 estado constitucional democrático.
Con nosotros España
se cumple la ley en todo el territorio,
porque sería suprimir
literalmente 1 de los 3 poderes del estado
que es el judicial.
Es inconcebible 1 España sin Cataluña
o 1 Cataluña sin España.
Con nosotros España no corre peligro.
Conocido
el sentido de la sentencia del Tribunal supremo,
quiero manifestar el absoluto respeto
y el acatamiento de la misma por parte
del gobierno de España.
¿A ver qué es? 1 mentira,
mentir a mi juicio.
Y creo que Además,
los telespectadores pueden opinar más o menos lo mismo.
¿Mentir es decir
algo que sabes que no es cierto
con la intención de engañar
usted qué les daría a cambio?
¿Les daría a cambio 1 referéndum o 1 amnistía?
No, ¿eh eh?
Aparte que es que es no, no es, no, es algo futurible.
Es que ya llevo 5 años gobernando.
Es que el el
el independentismo pedía la amnistía y no la ha tenido.
Lo que Han tenido son indultos condicionados.
Cuando dije no fue no,
cuando dije bueno, fue no.
Y le digo a los líderes independentistas
que nunca significa nunca
y que el Presidente lo dijo claramente,
no lo VA a ver referendo,
no VA a haber amnistía.
No sé cómo se puede explicar con más claridad, Diego,
no VA a haber autodeterminación,
no VA a haber referente.
Lo repetiremos por activa y por pasiva.
No es constitucional ni amnistía
ni nada de eso voy a decir más todavía,
es que no es constitucional.
Lo repito para que quede claro,
ni amnistía ni nada de eso.
Los indultos son constitucionales, el referéndum no,
ni tampoco la amnistía.
Y como este gobierno no se VA a saltar la constitución.
Lo importante en términos
de la justicia
española, es que
aquellas personas involucradas
los hechos que ocurrieron
último semestre del año, 2 017,
tienen que ser juzgadas
por parte de los tribunales españoles.
¿Esto VA a ocurrir eh?
A mí siempre me ha resultado muy llamativo que 1
partido Que se dice izquierdas,
como es el de izquierda republicana,
defienda la independencia de 1 territorio Rico,
entre otras cuestiones
porque dice
que paga mucho a los territorios más pobres
de España. Pero bueno,
nadie ha hecho tanto daño
a las instituciones catalanas como el independentismo.
Lo siento señores independentistas,
ustedes no tienen mayoría social en Cataluña
y lo saben 1 de los telespectadores es la amnistía,
algo que desde luego este gobierno no VA a aceptar.
Los líderes independentistas no son de fiar,
Han mentido a los catalanes
y yo lo digo claramente,
no quiero que descanse la estabilidad
ni la gobernabilidad de este país
en manos de las fuerzas independentistas. No lo quiero,
no lo quiero, e insisto
yo lo que quiero es 1 gobierno progresista
que no dependa de los independentistas.
Hay evidentemente 1 fracaso,
que es lo que representa hoy
el proyecto soberanista en Cataluña,
romper la ley,
pedir a los ciudadanos y ciudadanas
que desobedezcan esa ley,
es repetir los errores
de ese proyecto político y a naufragar.
La realidad es que su proyecto político ha fracasado,
sobre todo y ante todo porque ha sido
ha estado fundamentado en grandes falacias,
en grandes mentiras. Pero el independentismo
um pedía la amnistía,
pide 1 referéndum de autodeterminación.
No Han tenido amnistía,
no hay 1 referéndum de autodeterminación. Y lo habrá.
No lo habrá. Primero por convicción personal y política.
En segundo lugar, porque la constitución,
no solamente la española,
ninguna constitución en el Mundo
reconoce el Derecho a la segregación. Sí.
La Generalitat de Cataluña
hace cualquier intento de violentar
de Nuevo
el estatuto de autonomía y la Constitución española.
El grupo parlamentario socialista
y el gobierno socialista
aplicará cualquier artículo de la constitución
para defender la Constitución,
el estatuto de autonomía,
la legalidad,
la soberanía Nacional y la integridad territorial.
El independentismo gobierna contra Cataluña,
el independentismo gobierna contra todos
y cada 1 de los catalanes y catalanas.
Convivencia siempre. Independencia nunca.
Siempre les digo a los líderes independentistas,
tengan ustedes el valor,
Sean valientes. Por Primera vez en estos últimos 10 años,
salgan a la calle
y díganle a la gente que creyó en ustedes
que les Han mentido,
que les Han engañado
porque la independencia no es posible en Cataluña.
Yo se lo he dicho en privado
y también lo he dicho en público
y lo digo aquí para que conste en acta.
Yo no voy a permitir,
con todos los respetos
hacia los votantes de Esquerra Republicana,
que la gobernabilidad de España descanse
en partidos independentistas.
No lo voy a permitir.
Su propuesta es, dice usted, la de los independentistas,
la amnistía y la autodeterminación.
Bueno, eh, por la misma regla de 3 que usted dice,
yo puedo decir que eso no es 1 propuesta
a ojos del gobierno de España.
Para mí la propuesta es la agenda del reencuentro
y creo, además,
que el gobierno de España está haciendo 1 esfuerzo
para ese reencuentro.
Me explico
cuando tomamos las medidas de Gracia
Yo dije que teníamos que volver a aquel punto
en el que dejamos de escucharnos las partes
y eso es lo que estamos haciendo,
volver a tratar de reencontrarnos.
Gobierno de España ha hecho algo importante
y es hacer 1 análisis, 1 evaluación, 1 examen
de cuales Han sido las reivindicaciones del gobierno
de la Generalitat
desde hace más de 10 años,
45 puntos. Bueno, hay 1 en el que no nos eh encontramos
que no estamos de acuerdo,
radicalmente distinta a la posición
del gobierno del gobierno de España,
pero hay otros 44 en los que podemos avanzar.
Pues avancemos,
empecemos.
Si realmente queremos que el diálogo sea sincero
y sea verdadero,
pues empecemos por aquello
en donde podamos encontrarnos de 1 manera más fácil eh.
El diálogo es el método,
la constitución es el Marco,
lo que hemos hecho durante estos últimos 4 años
y yo creo ahí están las pruebas no,
Cataluña está muchísimo mejor en el año 2 023
que en el año 2 017
y por tanto tenemos que continuar en esa senda de
de trabajar por la convivencia eh
y y ahí VA a estar el partido socialista y y
y lógicamente yo sí tengo eh
la fortuna y el honor de de continuar 4 años más
como como Presidente del gobierno em
y en fin,
no me corresponde a mí decir que eso no constitucional.
Afortunadamente tenemos a tribunal constitucional para
eh eh dirimir todas esas cuestiones y otras no
y en relación con eh Con eh
fin la el proceso de negociación, ¿eh?
Bueno, es que John spell
Cataluña
tiene 1 representación parlamentaria de 7 escaños,
como lo tiene Esquerra republicana,
también como lo tiene
otras fuerzas parlamentarias,
y lógicamente nosotros no.
No rechazamos ni negamos la legitimidad,
a diferencia de lo que hacen otras fuerzas políticas,
no a nuestra derecha,
sea el partido popular
o sea Vox. Nosotros tenemos 1 Gran,
digamos, ventaja respecto a otras fuerzas políticas,
singularmente el partido popular,
y es que podemos hablar con todas,
con todas las fuerzas políticas salvo con 1,
y el partido popular solamente puede hablar con esa 1
única fuerza política
y no con el resto.
Y esta yo creo que también
es 1 de las principales virtudes
de 1 política que estamos practicando,
que es esa, la del diálogo